dun-dun-dun and what's up fool what's a
fool podcast welcome to the words our
full podcast people are welcome to the
show man thank you very much for being
here man we have a couple of
announcements today man now we need you
guys right now if you're watching this
show and you're near another computer or
you have um you're listening to it
somewhere but you're near a phone press
like right now [ __ ]
yeah press like and people who are
watching right now or listening or
listening I'm gonna roll here would you
please introduce you right now ladies
and gentlemen man we got Lisa Esparza
right here Rodrigo Torres Marcin Rizzo
yeah so please people just press like if
you're listening right now or watching
it or whatever you're doing a man in
your share it man
Sinaloan notes those apart on akula's
our message the other day by somebody he
said Philippe it sounds like my uncle my
deal bro my long-lost deal until
Philippe's my dear friend and
furthermore you when you're early
when you're young you never thought that
you never do that so my gonna consider
you of my all like my uncle yeah [ __ ]
that I know you like the momma never had
what do you miss a mage yeah unless you
start looking grandpa is too fast I mean
come on yeah well you had there know
that man tell me doc Lisa is from from
Dayton Ohio right yeah and you know I
didn't know that that ballet is to like
the breeders but didn't know we nee nee
nee nee nee nee nee therefore Dayton
Ohio you're supposed to be in a song
right in your home he likes ya bro were
talking about that [ __ ] ya know they're
from Oakwood Ohio which is like 10
minutes outside of Dayton the suburb the
rich suburb well and then that's when
want the other sister I want to say
names and stuff but there was an
incident with ups and a packages where
you worked at UPS something
arriving and she got arrested recently
no a long time ago October compressor
huh Kelly didn't that's a woman of
readers
that's not heroin right yeah they were
twins were twins so but Kim was already
in the Pixies they're a big heroin scene
in Ohio would you pick it up somewhere
else huh I just think she had probably
used it somewhere else gotta feed this
all calling ups over and over and over
and over
where's my package worse my packet oh
and they were like why is this woman
jonesing for her yeah that was a long
time ago that was like - no I was like
90s it was on the news oh no a lot of
people were talking about there they
were like in musicians and [ __ ] yeah and
that's always been like a famous story
that's a career I don't know that and
also - like what a lot of people used to
do to not get busted was FedEx drugs
right I you delivered a package recently
I do I've delivered a couple weird
packages and your most recent one that
you delivered so uh I picked up from
this one fancy hotel in downtown and I
know in Hollywood right and these guys
right here deliver these shorts to this
address
and then it was just like you shores and
like you know you know in a bag right
some Drive you know I'm like what the
[ __ ] is it just being like cheese most
let's see you know I don't make a video
violating the claw ya ain't got a lot of
use on [ __ ] tick tock so I'm like
looking through because it has a bunch
of zippers right so and one of the
[ __ ] PI's has they're like water
[ __ ] like cash and then I'm like I
don't know if I want to check the other
pockets because I'm like afraid like the
you know like oh we know where the show
was that you know it was deliberate
money money and I don't know what the
other pockets had bro I'm running with
it it must have been like [ __ ] like
$500 is that big yeah so it was a lot of
money so they're not but I've been in a
bag they put in a bagger Oh jack it was
just like it was inside uh it wasn't
said some cargo shorts and in
Technicolor like a paper bag you know
shopping bag shopping bag yeah and then
one time I picked up from this hotel
there's motel in South LA the guy gave
me an envelope now you drop it over this
address on alright money or what I don't
I don't look inside the envelope was it
was sealed but I like doing those rides
because a transporter
yeah balki drug mule da I don't care
you're doing something you're I want to
tip you that's good that's good that's
good and lift money brother
Tony's Hamilton but I like doing these
long rides because I love with a ride so
the one that the cargo trailers from
like Hollywood to [ __ ] Irvine and I
enjoyed it because I got paid in my car
he knows I just listen to music you
talking to those shorts huh should I
just cancel there right cheesy but I'll
forget cuz I already forgive like seven
months that's for you guys I got it at
that uh Gilroy uh that mission oh nice
st. Genesius the patron saint for actors
and comedians I was gonna give it to
your birthday with that other one I gave
you that out Saint Christopher what what
what I was gonna tell you you had you
found a date before right
what you mean like a pipe in all that oh
yeah one time uh whatever these uh this
couple right I dropped them off and then
when I was driving another lady got in
the car she was like so they left like a
case like a glasses sunglasses case and
the ladies I don't think you want this
in your car and I looked in there as
well getting two bags of crystal meth in
a pipe bro yeah they do with it I sold
it bro my profits no I I threw my
documents my healing crystals live like
that before one time I delivered or like
a baby bird like in a little shoebox to
like a hospital yeah I do stuff like
that bro yeah don't you take it to a
veterinarian wouldn't be no hostile
Reading area I don't know call of
bo-beautiful
there's like two little personal shoebox
that it was like a sparrow or like a
toucan look you know I was just like
your nosy with the shorts but now with
the birds nano militaria because I know
it's a nano more yeah I know what I know
what I'm delivering I don't know what I
was delivering is short like animal yeah
it was it was like two little birdies
like yeah I transferred them to like a
little animal hospital yet I would put
go to a doctor well they came out they
came out and they imagine and then one
time I delivered uh there's one lady who
like worked at this like fancy like
placing Encino she lives in Highland
Park she gave me like a key that she
forgot to like drop Bob and I just
transported key so I don't stuff like
that you know what's happened is in
terms of like people like lose their
phones I realize one time this one liked
all African guys I brought the [ __ ]
that's how they talk he's a do thing you
can give me a ride to over here my phone
broke but when we get there I'll give
you $100 bill and I thought should I do
this I don't know what are those hundred
dollars bill - yeah yeah but your
livelihoods in that phone though man
yeah so they all right cool let's go and
I was driving them he was talking it's
like I want to show you that uh he was
talking about Africa and when we get to
the place he's like walking away what
about my hundred dollars oh yes okay
I'll be back and he goes inside I'm
waiting for 20 minutes he comes out here
you go yeah so you know people that
people from Africa are nice people like
yeah dude
so now let's go man oh honey dollars off
yeah cuz it was like no [ __ ] like cuz
I've done those cash rights too you know
where people just their phones are lost
or some like that I'm gonna have a guy
run into the car
[Laughter]
ah well my lips were yesterday and he
wanted to do that with baby over five
stars oh yeah oh hey there I get in a
car bro like like sometimes like your
car bro have snacks yeah if we have
muscle pants
oh yeah right and he was telling me that
was his all make up on the party man
like yes he's talking like I never seen
myself on before ha ha you never been to
7-eleven they try to charge you 75 cents
why I don't want to correct about though
they don't not trying really our choice
we try to hey that's funny dude
but yeah so I go to this place then I
buy a bunch of of me
and I even my car me hopefully you know
they give me five stars so here we're
talking about a long time that he had um
he had um he had also alka-seltzers bro
did you feel sick in the car yeah and he
had a bottle water everywhere and I said
I think the part about bottle water is
opening it
oh I hate what my customers do that when
they taste it bust the see I used to
work your knife but not anymore
haha so I get too many confrontations
they like I will pick up like a girl who
is fine and when we get to where she's
going to go let's go inside I have a
couple of dream hahaha and he goes you
know man
I always say no but then it happens a
lot of times you know and then people
are drunk it doesn't happen 81 - you
have a good time man
but little I was looking at him Rob Lowe
maybe the one I set you up bro like that
what they're into you know like getting
the boyfriend jealous ex yeah I also
tell you man the weirdest [ __ ] I told
Roger you know what happened when I
picked up this one girl Saturday night
right and I took her god
it was late at night and I seriously
wanted to write to
but it was right or for this one he
picked up mere night haha it was weird
lady it was late at night I picked up
from San Dimas I took it to Compton was
like 35 miles all right all right i'ma
get like 40 bucks so then it was it was
crazy she was telling me like yeah like
she told me that when her father passed
away that she went to go to shoe into
Mexico right because he was in a coma
for five days and when she got to the
ranch he was like I never get mattress
on the floor pass out she's like wait
how come he's not in the hospital
oh you don't want to go to the hospital
so he's been in a coma for five days and
he's been passed out again the on the
floor another no man I was it cows but
no mattresses yeah yeah we don't want
the Dodgers coming like what the [ __ ] is
going on so then she fell asleep and
then when she woke up they told her yeah
I your dad I'll pass away and the
mortuary came to take home and she's
like what the [ __ ] and she told me in a
week of yeah and so she told me that she
thinks her dad's still alive Wow but she
says you know like the guy that they
caught that Chapel I think they sold my
dad to be a like cuz he looked like a
chopper they sold them to the [ __ ]
cartel and they passed him out is that
in couples out there right now she said
I follow the complaint with that I had
with the NYPD and all this stuff and she
was telling me this thing I was like
what the [ __ ] man and she gonna kill me
do like it was just a weird great story
and I was driving I was scared oh my
gosh let this right and ready and when
did she say that her dad got it her dad
died she he that in 2012 so they had him
like in like like what like 2012 and in
that like like a little bit after like
two times and then when they caught it
was like in 2013/14 and he's skipping in
2015 there yeah yeah so my gears like
you dad and she said it was very cool I
went when her dad passed away when it
passed away that the whole family had
money then [ __ ] start opening up
businesses so it's like yeah I'm again
like yeah he's so I know they [ __ ]
sold them to a [ __ ] the cartel or
like the [ __ ] the chapel's people and
she said that she's like I know you
think I'm crazy but I'm gonna be on the
news
whatever somebody you know what think
I'm crazy they are
and I said I'm not a rapist or nothing
I'm gonna creep or anything but at the
lyft driver when I went to work to fix
my I was getting like a ingrown toenail
so what to go see her again but she just
not no pain I took care of it already
before you get bad you know yeah after
the lower pain done yeah so my let her
pick me up somehow and we're not talking
about feets yeah cuz I told him what I
was doing in there yeah man
oh you know my feet are kind of hurt too
he was driving a Honda Fit dog really
ever did a commercial for a Honda yeah
of tope in the backseat yeah
and he said he told my whole life story
dude he told me his mom died and and he
kept that Honda Fit uh-huh but then he
was telling me that he used to work at
his job right when his mom died and he
used to work at his warehouse just in a
warehouse guy yeah but they were they
found out that he could run run programs
I guess ah make programs from where to
him we're promoting him so he invented
his program for this job that made that
job two million dollars extra every
really damn so he didn't work to know
more probably try to go back over there
they took get the [ __ ] out here right
yeah so he said that with mom died he
went over there ask for money dawg and
he gave $10,000 to bury his mom that's
it bro and also I can I'm not a lawyer
or anything bro but I wouldn't did not
cast that check and use that as proof
that the only soft yeah yeah right back
to they gave you money could be like
something like that so man you were more
worried about his feet though yeah so I
was telling him that you're here like a
planetory also so I told her man I said
you can go to a doctor or you could
doing two things man for that plantar
fasciitis
buy a box of golf balls and just lay on
them for like four five minutes at a
time eight times a day you're gonna
write aid and take your feet your shoes
off and lay on that foot machine yeah
and let them make measure though your
weight so you can have the right sole
yeah
man you know a lot about feets haha I'm
a podiatrist I get my toes ha ha ha base
to blow the door Cory that is our tragic
and she tell him the story that the limo
driver in Chicago told us seatbelt and I
told you about that before he builds all
your crazy dogs I never I never take off
my seat belt huh but telephone
oh man first of all they got a picked us
up you were wearing no dress shoes Hugh
what a little crotch not to make that
too it like they say fat shame they were
but one of people man and not just fat
people but there's just people that buy
a pair of tennis shoes and never tie
them again yeah slip off you just
squeeze it all loose right with no
shoelaces or Joey Tyler style dude on a
2001 dog now you wear the I lose a suit
- yeah well yeah I was a big tall dude a
big tall a big fat like he lost weight
but he's still fat you know what a fat
toes man that one of the big fat dudes
they picks you up and you're in here it
really too hard he goes all right I'll
help you with the luggage
yeah he's sweating too so we are I'm
stroking a purple house trouble you to
put the seat belt on do they you know
see brother we save your life about hey
we're one because you want to hear a
tragic story about seatbelts that my
brother was in a car accident he went
into a lake he went into a lake oh but
before you before you started the story
Chuck Boyk chuck Bartowski it sound like
[ __ ] already but yeah
they're all stoic government so I die
dude that's and so he said that brother
flew into a lake and everybody that was
not wearing a seat belt got to get got
to live bro yeah and they couldn't open
his seatbelt he died yeah I was gonna
ask you was yes big because if you're
tied your body is tight on that seatbelt
is hard to print that but it well if it
locks right locks and you can press that
button that button doesn't lock so
what's it look good when you do that
water pressure made me like you can't I
don't know I don't know maybe the body
was all turned or he broke an arm or
something you know I don't know let's
take a break and look at that video man
laugh at out Bret Hart yeah no I mean
some people have been hurt or injured or
killed or couldn't get out whatever in
time or they were trapped and that's
whatever but it's very rare and it's
more it's more rare than Isis live sane
right because I don't wear seatbelts
they fly through the windshield injury
comp like made worse because she
couldn't get out of her seat belt I feel
like that's uh remember when she had her
back yeah accident in the car and she
hurt her back
I don't know that why her name is coming
up in my mind but that's crazy man you
have been a car accident for a couple of
times yeah yeah you you were driving I
was driving around one time I got and
you still give you a lift driver no this
is before we live I'm really gone
I'd have insurance but I got hit hard
and this Asian lady right I still got
mine I got a lot of money from that
should do it and like I got through this
but no I went through insurance and me
my cousin got hit right we're in the car
and my other friend I can jeez some
Asian guy his mom told him don't don't
say that you were there we don't want to
be in any kind of you know we don't want
to get involved in that stuff and we got
like [ __ ] like five hundred dollars
each and I got a $5,000 for my car to
fix my my old cell
and when I went to the cheapest place to
[ __ ] fix my cards I can keep the
resident lucky funny dude
my baby mama hit somebody
which one one of them hit somebody bro
yeah she hit somebody and she got money
and she came out of the car crying cuz
you're pregnant
uh-huh and then threw it all kinds of
stuff
we got paid bro even though we had the
possibility because she said that guys
stop other southern ain't [ __ ] and you
said she's the one we went to a bar I
had to go to this place to put like the
electric shock on my back yeah it was
hot yeah what pain though did you just
said yeah I lied to them like I like to
give my ha ha no but I did keep saying
it was you hurting other people then
yeah brother tow truck driver with
Armenian bro haha alright let's just say
that all people are shaded not just
Armenians but a Capon in any country
yeah but happen didn't happen in a
downturn our lane he said don't move
right and then bla bla bla go my my um
my look Mike I see the lawyer and then
they were all connected bro chiropractor
oh [ __ ] she probably knew them too bro
right third accident pregnant in the end
we I don't know how much money we got I
see a dime I saw that a medical
appointment huh but that's how they
fluff the payments though yeah but you
got you got also like remember what you
say hurt you before oh yeah cuz if you
say something different again but the
thing is with the back you can never
really tell yeah that's what's up with
the back so you can get away with oh I
got pain you have no pain yeah don't
touch it there
I got hit dude I got sued nasty dude
realize come out of Guitar Center right
there I was working for mondo you told
me [ __ ] somebody up what time what I
mean [ __ ] somebody
drugged no I ran over remember we ran
over the dog with the little civic
remember that but no dude so I'm coming
out right there I don't know what that
Street is right there on Hollywood it's
a sunset and I'm coming out and I'm just
looking right because it has cars parked
right there okay I'll go now
so I go and there's to come and you know
how they always say you care about it
know where this fool came out of nowhere
though he was going like 65 miles an
hour on that little sheet and he hit me
that one time I had the whole door
smashed in for like I don't know like a
year dog so he hits me dog dude the
truck almost tips oh yeah and I'm in
shock I didn't even know what hit me I
didn't get knocked out or nothing but it
happened huh and then the it was a young
Armenian dude he pops up [ __ ] this right
call the cops yeah
and dude cops take forever to come oh
yeah first of all I thought they're
gonna be are you okay though get out of
the street get the truck out of the
street there they are man I'm thinking
I'm gonna get paid dog cuz I'm on this
dude hit me and everything right if we
lay on the floor put the mother's body
dude two days later Felipe in the mail
dog so it happened like it must have
happened within hours of the dude I get
a thing that that dudes suing me and in
in in all state and he's saying that
like dude I caused them all this pain he
can't sleep at night dude all these
shitty but the church they're paying
them off right and do not even have [ __ ]
you knows over here making money I was
getting a little bit doing stand-up with
Felipe like I ought to do pennies were
tight dog yeah so dude and then they
wanted $500 dude for a deductible to fix
the truck and I'd even have it what am I
gonna go with my head down and ask my
parents for it as I [ __ ] dog so dude I
go right there up the street from where
you guys used to live in Glendale and I
go yeah so I want two months because I
started hitting like good you get
suggestions from your insurance and then
I'll go here go there and everybody
finally [ __ ] yeah I go to these Armenian
dudes [ __ ] it just smoking cigarettes
like nothing dawg yeah in the man goes
oh you're Mexican I have Mexican in my
family look
these are all my paints he walks through
the whole place yeah it already looks
shade you had a couple prices in there
working dirty as hell you know they
probably you should work if you wanna be
hires and these little don't worry you
have problems I can tell no more yeah
man so how much is it gonna cost for
deductible income you with me there's no
deductible okay I'm gonna pay you this
is what you do sounds like my landlord
bro so do so I go back to Allstate and I
tell him and I'll say well we suggest
you shouldn't do this he's not a
reputable body shop guy [ __ ] that right
so so the guy goes and meets with army
and duty and he's all you wait over
there
start yelling at each other
this [ __ ] dude this thing's gonna
class this shit's gonna cost this this
hinge gonna cost this and you know and
cuz the thing is without state they want
to use all original parts but they also
know so this was all yeah we'll use
original parts wink-wink charge leaf
original parts but he used aftermarket
parts you can see the different gaps now
Mickey Mouse so he's all the deck comes
out you saw what are you doing this this
is Mickey gonna be right this in that I
was like [ __ ] the scam done I don't have
500 bucks dog before the fighter putting
our truck party but they [ __ ] put a
ladder rated I just want this truck
fixed let him go
all right now you're gonna get 250 from
me just for doing business just to do it
all and I was just like dude should I
take it he kept ten so I held that [ __ ]
dawg so anyways so I mean I knew it was
gonna be [ __ ] dawg
cuz we do the door was a little off so
you come back you know we're [ __ ] and
then it took forever to get the truck
back is all here's another 250 for your
time and
Wow damn and then now you have $500 yeah
as long as it gives me from point A to
point B but uh yeah dude I got a little
swindle but do they were crooked as [ __ ]
in there do and then dude the dad go
pick up the truck the state of
California automotive investigative
services pulls up to that place
hey how you doing dude you get a truck
oh yeah we might need to talk to you I'm
okay I'll be in my truck right there so
he still owes me like two parts to the
truck and I just never went back I'm
just [ __ ] dog but that dude that dude
didn't get hurt or Nothing dog nothing
dog and then I looked him up dude that
full suit seven people out there it's
[ __ ] dude it's a racket dogs in there
all connected and doing that that that
do that the body shops all I know
chiropractors I know doctors whatever
you know cheaters even eyes can get
damaged incorrect your hair by the time
I got my truck come on me get the
[ __ ] jail well my friend one my
friend was and I still like that and he
said they were to uh the chiropractor he
said he made a joke he said bro look
that you see your x-rays just you have a
lump in your breast too ha ha ha ha it
was damaged in accident no you bet your
joke just joking around at the [ __ ] you
did that with me when it came down to
other stuff they brought in some other
food x-rays dog and a real scam and
they're like no no man is kept by
another guy x-rays and they're all to
connect them at him and then that's why
insurance is so expensive
yeah and their workman's comp saw messed
up because it was saying oh man but I
mean your deal no but you're making it
worse for everybody making everything
low all the costs go up and all that
stuff people say that oh man this kept
passing me a small chain without shaking
yeah bro but you're [ __ ] up our laws
our air the environment the reason
Elliott bad air certain people who do
that sort of thing regularly like wasn't
that baby mama bit yours
done that way Armenian guys they all
sound like him and the ones the Latino
guys don't like the cab driver my live
driver oh yeah whatever you need you
know what I was really hurt from that
accident dude my side hurt for days my
man that fool rocked me nasty dog and
then I told that shirt off there's
nothing we can do about it because
according to how you were hit it's your
fault oh my gosh so is there any way I
can sue this really where were you right
there coming out of that little side
seat on the side on the side I have the
two doors how is that your hint like I
came out and I do truck he plowed into
Maya oh wait but he was in City Ballet
for because they have the park community
you can't see this he's all listen going
up against you in that city I'll a you
might a little just like go to your bank
account and take out $20,000 I'm are
there's not even $20,000 there not a
good 20 bucks in the bank account right
now yeah it's 27 but that's how it goes
that's why I was telling you when you
get hit by behind it's automatically
your fault yeah hit somebody from behind
the hotel your truck was was that
Armenian guy what were you driving I was
driven that's when I was in the
pest-control truck for like two weeks
the mondo got finally got rid of funny
the horrible dog but though how did you
meet this guy their meaning guys I was
going to play it's right there off for
now those have Fernando when it does a
turn Fletcher a little bit
Home Depot no no no well that's a budget
really yeah John woods with widow
no nor me need you okay it was just
called like John's Auto Body but it was
like you know whatever his name people
don't know man everything if your looks
like these body guys and like go there
and talk to them and really tell him how
you [ __ ] up your car and we throw in a
real sad story like my old lady's
ex-boyfriend her husband found out I was
cheating on his wife with her and they
he try to kill me wrecked
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro I'm gonna cook you up dog
yeah yeah we'll come up with a better
story Dover they hired assassin that's
what it's if you cater to somebody
they're like that happened to they'll be
they'll have a soft spot yeah and I mean
I happened to meet here i'ma hook you up
bro
well if you're going to a flashing bro
that we're gonna get all the best parts
ah they're gonna check your ass it's
better to go legit in the Andes okay so
guys Matt will look at you and go listen
man I know you can't afford this but
here's the part that I need I want you
to go over there on Mission Street or
Mission Avenue in LA down to a lane and
buy the parts and I'll put it in for you
yeah but they have out the windshield
time yeah and mufflers goes more flares
way I've got a little kicker Parker's
doozers I said it with a 12 pack all day
waving a dirty a red flag bro it's a big
old fat dude for years ever dude because
that's what we were that's it Hussein
would take me to go get the carvings I
taught I wonder big dog had his window
busted out bro took him away I broke big
dog window broiler and I get the dirtier
fixed okay hell yeah dude he's all you
go little more Harless bro I was like
all right let's go broke with someone
else first and it charged them an arm
and a leg dog and you know that fool he
was like hell nah that's what's up fool
well I don't know you lady put a video
up today and about beating assault and
don't tell my lane
oh that's a long time ago yeah but it
was like an old story I saw what
happened a homeless guy so what it was
like it was like two years ago
so I guess it's about with her no so she
was working in downtown the work she's
gonna work goes in downtown LA in the
morning like morning yes she worked at
that let's call it a fashion district
place and then she was going and there's
a guy who's like he look like he was
like on crystal meth right so he he
followed her I was following her like
yeah he was where he was riding a
scooter he was like he looked [ __ ]
you look like he's probably 20-something
but he looked crack that he was tall and
he was following her and then that uh
which was going into her up into her
office the guy [ __ ] cornered into the
[ __ ] into an elevator he slapped her
ass and like she was afraid she was
crying she was screaming and there
in her her boss came out and her gay
co-worker came out and they [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you doing the guy ran away
and she told me that and I was doing
lift or on downtown LA and she was so
many other streets it was and I was
[ __ ] drying around looking for the
guy I saw the guy dude and he kept
disappearing cuz I cuz you know like how
there's a streaker does one way streets
in downtown LA to I was following Scott
for three [ __ ] hours dude and then
collapse never came to that point so I
called the Casa a I see the guy and
they're like okay we're gonna look for
him and then I kept seeing him so like I
stopped and I saw cop Park say I'm
there's a guy who they love he sexually
assaulted my girlfriend you know and
it's like kept a whole bunch of people
and they're like and they're telling me
okay if you see him you can't do
anything about it because he can sue you
if you [ __ ] maybe run after him and
he'd runs into the street cuz I do I was
driving him I was driving and I will
like drive like Puckett I would see him
he will look at me and he knew I was
walking chasing him anywhere and so he
kept hiding so then I saw that he went
into the CVS right there on spring and I
called the cops I know where he's at
he's right there and they [ __ ] got
him dude and I was on for three hours
like the inner corners at CVS hahaha
but I told step if it wasn't for me like
looking around for the guy he would have
gotten away you know because I just kept
falling my foot she told me at the
causeway and after they went to her out
to her job and they kept there like I
get information and they told everything
they're gonna see what's gonna happen
after that but if it wasn't for me like
partly chasing the guy he woulda got
away for a prosecutor though or what
happened I think he did yeah yeah your
girlfriend go to court and all that
stuff
criminal proceedings all that stuff I'm
not sure about that hey don't ever
before
yeah I'm not sure but he looked dude
when I will look at him he looked like
it was lost but I like his eyes like
they're like he was like [ __ ] on drugs
but for three hours bro like I was
falling his [ __ ] dude it's crazy
dude What's Up boo okay people shout out
to new listener outsider on Instagram he
listens while he's driving his tow truck
shoutout to towing people shout out to
foreign words on instagram hit him up
for your exotic needs lowest prices on
rare backwoods and sodas for n words
that's at for the letter n wo OD
he sent some foreign words man the
retired people lisa has been scouring
the earth for banana-flavored
backwoods and this guy right here this
cool guy he sent us one they're
expensive matter like two hundred
dollars each
you can yeah there looks like a black
market for them because they stopped
making stop me once for some reason and
this guy has banana flavor backwoods he
has great flavor backwoods and I think I
have a vanilla maybe there was like a
Russian no the Russian cream one that I
got right now this is hard to find I
don't have a grey portal
yeah I like to get mango also people I
told you they have banana one time at
the little like kiosk yeah cigarette
place that used to be one of those film
developing spots and they saw him and I
was like eleven dollars I don't know
about that and I passed and then you
can't find him and shut out to him
Anthony new years from Apple Valley
California
Rebecca Mendoza Pro a Gonzalez shout-out
to my son
who's out there working driving a truck
from Fresno to Ontario Ontario to Tucson
my little homie right there Anthony
what's up boo we're not we're watching
bro oh Lisa
my grandson bro and we went to watch how
was it good we didn't see any whales for
a long time even rare no no no just
right there off of Long Beach Pedro but
we go every year around my birthday but
this was a little later than usual yes
it was so maybe that's why that they
weren't out in the the wide-open part
that's like a two and a half hour trip
round-trip which is nice but it was cold
and we got out there no whales until we
got back to the shallow part there's
like this little space there where the
breakwater is the little jetty and you
cross through and so we parked and we
cut the engine and then we saw like five
yeah oh I have people that when they eat
Wells they say it tastes like like steak
or not here boy I gotta Wyatt like steak
or like uh like that shut up to Bianca
Omar Ricardo a nun Dez what up homie
next month also man this week we're in
Toppenish Washington Toppenish
Washington this Friday March 6th at
Legends casino only a hundred tickets
left
Griego Taurus March arezzo
Jay Lamont Midland Texas and Austin
Texas March 27 and 28 with Bruce Bruce
earthquake and Bill Bellamy people yeah
food is food a baby I had or left boots
Brad a funny ad meme this morning go
rich mom it wasn't wasn't were the one
about out he goes there's nothing a boy
wonder when a snack cart battered by the
airplane you know I ain't sleepy wake me
up something like that dog yeah baby
Bruce Bruce it kind of do they put it
like baby baby baby oh my best cop ain't
nobody back there one no candy don't let
him sit at I'm at the light at the end
like the last seat before like you know
your first class you and Bruce Bruce the
first class but the last seat in first
class because that cars going over there
put your brains baby buddy you don't
need nobody pass by user recipe Oh what
do we know here we all paid good money
to keep people like you out of here huh
remember who's bagging on that uh sure
dog are you gonna feed they're going
which all away it looks like your pants
gonna swallow your shoes baby blues
Bruce Bruce Bruce hit it also man
Coachella California
April 4th spotlight 29 Casino Oklahoma
City Oklahoma
April 9th through the 11th Bricktown
comedy club Los Angeles April 29th at
Belasco Theatre dr. Elaine yeah as part
of the Netflix is a joke festival Oxnard
California Rico and Mambo shut out April
30 to make third-level alive those los
angeles tickets by the way are on
presale right now until thursday and you
can get them with the code jokes and
we've already sold over half the tickets
for that show
just yesterday so you gotta hurry or
they're gonna be gone in a couple days
that's okay this meal I get a whole
bunch of stuff places right that
festival yeah I think Dave Chappelle is
doing one at the Hollywood Bowl and I
can't imagine comedy outside like the
Beatles air right you're not gonna be
here dissipate sound unless they've got
the audience might well and I don't
think they do because it's for concerts
audience oh no I just can't imagine
that's crazy a fine Bruce Bruce page
yeah you guys vote yesterday yeah you
voted yeah yeah I did not vote and I'll
tell you why why cuz I was very busy at
first but then when I went to my son's
school to vote in the one half hour time
that I had I got there and there were
like in the room there were probably 20
voting booths right a little polling
booth yeah little iPad things right
then six of them were being used six of
them were being used and so I get to the
check-in place and he's I gave him my
name and matched the address and then he
goes oh they're saying you have to vote
provisionally provision 30 years boating
I've never had to vote provisionally why
haven't registered no or switching
parties doing sorts of stuff like that
I've never been asked to vote
provisionally and I said why and I don't
wanna go off on this volunteer he's a
volunteer he doesn't write he's just
saying what it says so he said he said
that's what it's saying he said because
the system is inundated [ __ ] this system
I was so mad and then I had to I had to
go take my son to the dentist I had and
then we had to go to laughing other time
to go and I couldn't I didn't have time
to fill out a provisional ballot either
like and do all that and I didn't like
the idea of having to do that that
really pissed me off
you're not a criminal or nothing like
that and how hard it is to vote right I
mean I could I just have one caste
system that they're using somebody's
friends who's all that [ __ ] and they're
[ __ ] it all up for everybody I was
really mad about that what does that
mean the system is inundated is that why
they're only six booths filled and there
are ton of people around the corner like
I waited in line for 20 minutes to get
there the people where is that for two
hours yeah and there's a people are
complaining somewhere in our lane I
don't know I didn't like I change the
channel because a ridiculous story yeah
we water a rated rated they were pissed
that they ran out of my rate yeah yeah I
rate want my normality they mad that
they have no I voted down everybody want
to do the I voted selfie huh yeah last
year and I put it on video to a photo
like seven of the pattern
you just grabbed before somebody stopped
crying
virtually combined amazon 70 or 78 year
old 21 year old people crying yeah I
just voted what it doesn't count
why that's fine you know I donate blood
and they don't get i donate blood
yeah but [ __ ] they give you cookies and
a lemonade yeah that's good enough right
there for me man I went to go vote I got
that 7:30 half-hour before close nobody
was there and then there was a old-ass
lady she was like 75 year old coughing
like a sealed oh no oh yeah you know
what's going on we're on the verge of a
pandemic Lee oh I don't have anything
yeah but once you just grab your little
hand right there like you're gonna sing
it to a microphone cover it are you for
real and now you're gonna touch the
ballot now you're gonna have yeah and
she's all excuse me Damien could you
work with this gentleman here Dan I hope
you're gonna go wash your hands
what'd she say she got all mad and
walked away she's probably to go wash
your hands
oh sure the volunteer yeah paid 125
bucks I heard a date yeah I didn't I
thought they're all volunteer my people
got paid it's usually retirees instead
yeah give them they're given the bigger
book and uh we'll see you guys pick it
up at eight oh eight oh one that's crazy
dude hey you guys believe that bro that
[ __ ] the Biden really is taking a
Super Tuesday well he took a lot of
states but I think it didn't matter in
the end because what's-his-face won
California
yeah but it's like they just if so many
people want I was listening to Fox News
yesterday and they seem to want Bernie
to come out as the front-runner
because that's I think who Trump wants
to battle basically talking about a
reality show battle oh that's who he
wants to go up against I think because
then he can fight socialism he can bring
down you know what I mean like the
people who think that Bernie is all
about social right but you know that
it's easy for his base it's easy to get
his base to follow him people only know
one territory although in the right
in the beginning when when burning was
first running a lot of my more rational
Republican friends and family were they
liked Bernie they liked a lot of the
things about him and they didn't like
Trump because of other reasons but I
don't know how those people feel today
because there's been so much time and so
meant so many opportunities to smash
Bernie down you know in the press and
whatever and you know use his policies
and twist things especially the the
whole tax the 1% stuff that he wants to
do you know tax 1%
shout out to Johnny o Daniel who showed
up to the Chicago with Emily Oh Daniel
and the fam all the fam bro they were
deep show it so eat up man he was like
um I think Johnny is on that raw diet
still maybe no he was on the OL meat
though oh it's all me there's nothing
else nothing else he was doing but he
said that he didn't get none of the
backfires like everybody talks about you
get for a couple weeks on Johnny Johnny
huh Johnny how do you respond here let
us know how you feel after how you felt
at the very last of em he's a I think
for our Saturday Saturday morning he had
like a stack of ribs right I'll be there
you like it
I used to like bacon bacon yeah what my
Chuck I tried machaca
yeah you see that when we went to Lucy's
know Martha's dry Wanda my mother to
bring bags all dried up for Sinaloa
Michael do J Nancy's J&S has the best my
check out burritos pepper that chili
relleno burrito the first one I ever
that was the first Jaina bellow across
the strip of ordonez right now my cannon
but the golf course that plays man
if you're a pot head man it's like
perfect broke you go in there all stone
or drunk and you go no way I'm just
gonna [ __ ] three corn dogs but how
about that hot dog they had to swap with
the tortilla and then it has like
lettuce and then drizzle with guacamole
Thank You legal the guy I used to make
hot dog with cheese inside a tortilla
for Isaac they have a burrito there
that's not the do they have any meat in
it but it's just a green chile burrito
and it's like Rajas broiler bumpers
pride they have the post romney burrito
there too oh my gosh there's a place was
somebody there though yeah yeah but they
never know fight milk is hungry the
budget could be there were those girls
that kind of look at a cube but they
like they open their mouth or missing
teeth Robby some yeah little vampire
chick robbing somebody with a smile like
wow and they like this there are missing
party - you gotta bring that party to
[Laughter]
talk about these I don't know if you
ever total of the podcast but you and uh
Willy went there one night it will he
was real buzz and then like he started
helping the lady like sweet and half bar
master - the cheese fried by the way
yeah jeez
but you said that story though yeah
Willy was we went through a top row they
over the old lady was there and then
like she stole that right now yeah
really good I think you got a sweet girl
out do it it starts weeping bro did you
get a discount it's all cash with them
it is all cash that's sure huh you tired
sweep your brother retire bad that you
know good karma for sweep you see
crackhead sweeping all the time bro they
you know I used to do it in Mexico bro
ha ha I mean what bro sleep eh maybe a
little house yeah 24/7 they're different
than Albert those those yeah Albert
those is the one with fries too or
that's that that's not our cheese aren't
chili cheese we didn't get chili cheese
right but we got cheese fries yeah maybe
melt the cheese supposedly the to their
thing is the chili melted I got chili on
these fries I needed you to me yeah
we'll only put it underneath the lamp
cuz I've asked before I put a diamond
offer that up no no because they have
that rule and but I I asked could you
put it right there I have to [ __ ] out
the Hat chili fries with five dudes bro
do you you can't pluck it or do that
[ __ ] you can't take yourself yeah yeah
yeah baby fries are bond that's you
though in the pastrami there bro yeah
the best bus driver ever had on a
hamburger yeah a hammer but you know
we're a good person Omni is gold star in
Glendale but they're crispy those
pancakes do they're a little bit better
than um Denny's pancakes yeah they own
about the order of our the up to three
improv
I'm home alone me yeah so my god yeah oh
[ __ ] alone house yeah Winnetka I've
never had pancakes and ghosts no bro
it's different yeah home alone house
that was close [ __ ] man it didn't hit me
till after though but you know what was
cool as soon as we got there there was
people taking pictures people happy yeah
the one with the little kids and then
those other goons over there and right
when we walked out were all my guy there
I'm telling you man when people go - it
was cool oh that place is good - bro
shout out to a funky old man that works
I don't want to UM I don't want to [ __ ]
on your dreams right now but you [ __ ]
dumpster was just constantly just
getting attack we had a build a cage
around it to keep the rat food over
there I guess but you know what one
thing that they have that's bomber than
what you guys mentioned a steak
sandwiches to die people already but I
never order it I just ordered I when I
was eating meat brother the double
cheeseburger bro and all the foods are
good to imagine [ __ ] on it it's own
binary kind of yeah I gotta say hope
they brought ah what a you can't be
going to lucky boy trying to order
something to them like Asian salad and
it does make saddest brothers out there
yeah yeah [ __ ] that is black full of
[ __ ] chicken oil bro yeah
good to get something else it's not
Sally that's what it tastes like
it's just cabbage and I was gonna say
that uh that steak sandwich they do it
like a thought a dog they grab the bread
they hit it with mayonnaise and they
grill it again
yeah dude and that's it that's hang
which is ten bucks it's a bomb at her
blog he said that he was either no we
know no we used to go sprays house a
week he lived around the corner for him
from there shoutout to alice Katanga
that bring it up dinos burgers no no his
house is a macula but it is white pass
it is one of those it yeah they have
people go there cleaning but it's one of
those old sweet homes kind of like not
between like the generation like after
the Brady Bunch before a Reno wood
paneling what about Ari's Ares Ari's
it's like a gold it's gold burger job
ring like Jim's burger burger you've
been around longer and then doubles came
right there on that Street I mean you
try to competing against I'm about
double yeah there's another place man
with the Lucy Lucy Lucy yeah lupus lupus
lupus number two because the original
ones over there kind of more by P
cooperation yeah well that's the one I
have that they have a comedy show no
karaoke across the street right what
Lisa and I went over there brother they
could have way to sing but people
holding their mics report passes not the
karaoke karaoke book during the last two
carbon belt out like what can they get
their songs like all those like
old-school like you know like people
obsessed like that's their thing they
feel like a star that night we tell you
something real quick and this is why you
can't blow people up and nothing against
like you know that you got Megaman
starting a podcast you gotta start
somewhere but he has a good soul
whatever let it shine so look this guy's
already insane bro you know
I told Felipe the story and I use quite
how to pull monitor the size do you know
I love you dog but we can't be doing
this to this wall oh I didn't
okay I'll tell him to stop then my new
just let him think he can yeah so we're
doing a fundraiser across the street
from the airline mondo yeah and guess
who's guess who's over there
hosting the you know yeah takes the shot
drinks a beer you should try to attend
oh I'm already am I'm ready man and by
the way I know this guy this guy oh my
god you want other people's jokes what
was he doing that was funny so funny to
fondle do dumb [ __ ] like all another
comment it's all the cheap little like
you know thank God thank God he did he
didn't try to do Santa burgers like
music or his music here right and then
like rerun that one time we went to that
one political function dude they they're
over here like on the talent for me but
trying to get in the back and subs I go
back and then those dude I'm gonna but
everybody those type of dudes are like
they go someone they take off their
rings oh just trying too hard
Jose Rizal was there were his wife but
there were a lot of ladies there blonde
ever seen politician hos bro I've never
seen politician or groupies yeah a hos
but people who are who are just the
people in these parties people in the
bottom you're not up there bro yeah
[ __ ] filing dog they want to crawl to
the top so bad it's disgusting though oh
then and they want or they stop running
they talk [ __ ] about it of course of
course because I flew that post I can
share with the last gay workforce oh
yeah and wait to like something happens
on the investigation overall I always
knew that guy was crazy dude nothing
even happen yet always the wind but I
just unfold it probably when you were
working with him all oh yeah
let me shine your shoes oh you are
[ __ ] cutting people with a business
card so gross dude that is so gross yes
Johnny said what's up fools
I'm good lost 9 pounds and gained back
five a muscle by the end of the twenty
nine days last are a one and a half inch
in my waist feels good but first me oh I
had was a killer spicy mac and cheese
that um and then that Emily makes and
they watch it done with a yeah that's a
good man my brother has for the last I
don't know 20 years he's eaten like two
meals at every meal he'll eat - because
he's a construction worker plus he was a
roofer bus he that's hard to Galus one
with lemonade my dad would take two
gallons to work with him and then you
know Kool Aid was 29 dude it's all sugar
he would take two of those he would take
two or three bologna sandwiches he
wasn't vegetarian he you know he made
his own thing he would make two or three
bologna sandwiches and he would eat that
giant giant mean we didn't have a lot of
money he didn't go to work with much
construction works hard he also runs
five miles a day like he's pushing over
the broken ankle you need a rest
ankle fix Johnny that's what you need to
do forget about the meat diet
I'll tell me rocky like well we're like
when we didn't have jobs like a long
time years ago we're gonna open mics I
pulled bad yeah and I'm like what we do
it cuz we ready a spool you're gonna
have money to go buy food we don't have
money to go to open mic so we would eat
a whole bunch of where's house dealer
let's just stack up on calories and then
I get by the time you know we're back
home you know we'll have like so we just
kind of first up yeah burn out the out
of the food for the day doesn't mother
mom make good food or what or let's kick
it she's mean good for ya yeah you were
loaded man like when you're real sleepy
but you have a show to do and then after
this show you know why don't you get it
all wired up or you can tog eat yeah I
did a coke line for real 235 that's
pills a good shot your adrenaline that's
rather funny and um how was it so close
that [ __ ] out bro how was it born with a
comedian brother with a yellow hat
yellow beanie
I'll see cuz yeah his name is Ian Lara
yes we a lotta I didn't mention him on
my Instagram like he's funny or you in
the middle I forgot that was your crowd
right there dude I was like your people
that came out to his show for sure man
they're excited to begin Latino night
hasn't been like that yesterday forever
15 sure the the cattle head if I stood
to the end of the show I went to Reubens
partial yeah so so we're like like we're
all on stage a quick appearance Louisa
Andy Gonzalez Karl Arvin Yvette Linda
Chavez David Lin David Chavez so they're
all over on stage I took a picture they
kept on here he hasn't got get on the
stage you guys gotta move the party and
then we're like let's go upstairs and
then uh one of the barista no she left
though that won't grow birthday Darrin
yeah and after that Carrie and one of
the producers of our Brown Asia a like
her family's I got think he like company
had to pick you up from her family and
he she was pouring everybody sha David
or a meadow I met her in Oxnard she's
hello to me Haley I know what was the
Jose Chavez doing over there was he
pretending to be Felipe like a group
photo or whatnot the group photo but in
the videos doing shots down inside it
puts I was like these people think
I've always said you're not a real fan
if you don't know exactly who that
person is dude cuz you're gonna be like
oh you look kind of old Dutch you let me
get an autograph yeah had to fight
people though upstairs like do it shots
and I was like did these people think
they might do I feel like most the
industry now every time I see him I
invited Momo today but he's on a 500
calorie diet for 25 days about 35 pounds
Wow take that Jonny but it's not it's a
medically recommended program he's under
the one he had he was over 400 pounds
when I don't see him in January record
his special and then he's lost all that
weight since then he was having like
chest pains but also his blood pressure
was like 180 over 100 has were tied to
ten or something like that it was high
blood pressure and he was he was feeling
faint like just stop lying it all this
clothes are all loose yesterday so you
lose weight but he doesn't want to be on
this diet but he feels great yeah he's
got 15 more days of this and then
they're gonna put ad working out and
then change his diet a little bit
everybody follow one more Rodriguez and
tell him you can do it before he becomes
one mole because all the ways in to lose
[Laughter]
shut up to Ching Queen bro
Ching Queen is a big fan of the podcasts
out there you know our kids right oh oh
listen to the listen to the news on Fox
News they're telling me about how crazy
the tornado was in Tennessee in
Nashville 165 miles an hour oh my god
remember we D here we went to Dallas and
it took up that whole little community
yeah four knots to our flattened a dog
so I thought this fool lived in
Tennessee yeah right but he live in
Arkansas so I left a four message dog I
just heard they [ __ ] wreck your town
right he woke up like what you're
worried he's asleeping I'm gonna for his
family now but haha so they hear me up
this morning goes nah man I live in
Arkansas hey I'm gonna see you guys in
Oklahoma City his uncle has a farm out
there hilarious dude shut out to local
union for 18 iron workers oh yeah Al
Bundy guys funny name elbow knee god
that's funny dude good account name if
you know somebody else's house was then
near the home alone house it was another
movie to a nearby to with what house
near the G in Chicago near hand that
rocks the cradle I think we were science
oh yeah we're something yeah oh yeah
that's true and also Michael Jordan's
house wasn't too far from where people
were telling you guys to go further in
and you'd see Michael Jordan
wow that was fun I don't like when
people go to Chicago take pictures like
by the hugging that'd be numb up bro
really [ __ ] up being good or like
people have more of a fighting
connection to the house yeah that's
funny
didn't that lady come out the owner yeah
so mad but you said there were a bunch
of people from like all over all
different types of people there were
some Sikh people Malone has really
touched the world during the holiday
season the way that video no AirPort -
yeah if I if I lived at the house I
would just quit my job in just dying we
said make merchandise and make little
tours and [ __ ] yeah I'll make it look
like the inside the inside the backyard
not shot in there right no no no it's
all we're look in the back look at the
back with a tree woman that's a badass
house so if you looked at it but watch
out that documentary on Netflix called
the movies a Tomatoes and they show the
whole how it was shy on the side of a
[ __ ] school that's a whole when you
told me that she will dad hallways in
the rooms were too small for the camera
crew even the
and story on that was awesome yeah that
John County sir how like he only got
paid like 500 bucks for the whole day as
he did as a favor the pizza boy got paid
more than [ __ ] John Candy he worked
over 23 hours done yeah over one day it
was John Hughes like favor that you [ __ ]
is that you [ __ ] screwed me over bro
we got he's badass in that part yeah
when the mom gets a right to be the
poker king yeah I think the Pogo King
right like a parody of them but it's a
lot of poke call themselves see the Pope
sweating worried I'll watch it American
grieving yesterday and they show the
lady who robbed an a-rod man she was
like his confit on his site she got his
life all organized and she's like a life
coach she said one of the women that you
look at her he was she could be a
stripper but she also can watch my kids
later on she could take care of my kids
like but they were really giving her the
audio counter pay the bills
yeah you know what I'll give you guys a
salary of $5 a week allowance pay your
bills
now pay your bills and then the rest of
it we're going to this account I get to
manage and I'll invest all that for you
but you'll still have everything paid
and so for a while there's no note it
you don't notice that things aren't
getting paid and you're getting money
but she's got the bulk of the money and
that was a tricky it was the first one
yeah she took his first six-figure check
he went to the ATM after air he tried to
use his debit card and it was declined
he's like surely there's a problem I
just deposited a six-figure check and
they said no there's no money in here
nothing came in when she went he went to
Miami to go play over there she hooked
up and married someone
Miami tube she mentioned like six
husbands yeah what you should know what
the money not opping she had a woman who
worked for her who was a friend of Ricky
he got her a job working for this woman
she said I was really interested in like
learning how to do like life coaching
stuff and and and talking about trades
and in investing people's money for them
as a woman wasn't certified to do that
and she said I was really interested in
learning that but all we did was shop
all the time she's been that much no go
for it my my ex ex-girlfriends mom was a
high school so like she said work at a
hospital and then one time one should
see like it'd be like a clean lady and
the elevators like hit her [ __ ] like
clothes on her [ __ ] cowboy she she
sued the place I heard that she got
[ __ ] eighty thousand dollars and then
the whole two years I was with her she
never had a job bro and then like after
two years like she's like I'm gonna run
out of money because she just kept
[ __ ] spending money you know I had a
nice place you didn't come from we're
getting a hospital and like the
elevators close on her elbow and ideals
like almost hundred thousand dollars and
then for like two years she didn't work
I remember she was paying like right at
this nice [ __ ] condos and like
housing that high so how do you she
wasn't war was going on and towards the
end like chanting [ __ ] not to move to
a smaller place like she didn't work for
like two years it's trippy how people
get built out of their money cuz me in
Philly but we're talking about and then
all his victims and how much they got
like Kevin Bacon got it for 14 million I
care about the Bernie Madoff yeah but
for 14 million books you don't know your
you don't know what's happening with it
and you get statements because they
falsify statements yeah boom anybody's
game you get fake statements that look
legit and there's here's your money
here's what it's doing how do you know
that the statement you get each month
for your investment is legit or not you
have to really trust this person one of
the basketball players said I will try
to get a hold of her and she went goes
Don
[Laughter]
my agent brought that one right here
agent went over there and said listen
she got it how can you find out your
bladder have more cars than you she had
five cars in the driveway and yeah you
don't want yeah this woman had no
certification to be doing that but yeah
the flow dollars like Merton wasn't
Madoff you know he worked on that
principle of referrals only so we had to
be friends of friends friends of money
it always had to be over a million
invested cuz wasn't his returns like
really big and only a regular returns
like that's the thing you can't all
somebody who's not already looking for
quick money you know this woman said
that's too good to be true she was doing
the first of all six green on both
people she stole these people yeah for
no fees you told everybody nobody that I
do it for oh yeah oh yeah she always
worked for hilarious is that what got
him raw Dennis Rodman date her in his
piece how much did you jack from him or
something like that yeah it was a twelve
years only ten years I think he ended up
getting five a million or one point
something back or something like yeah
Rick with it was too but not a lot no
yeah he thanked her
that's from selling all the stuff she's
bought she doesn't have any income to
pay them back stuff but she might have
some left over but if you don't you're
[ __ ]
he's asking for a bullet in the head man
yeah and she was she was black a black
woman even though she's very very
light-skinned but she was a black woman
so these athletes were like it felt good
to be working with a person of color
woman of color running her own business
and so she [ __ ] Ricky Williams best
friend his business partner the real one
he said this see she knows that these
athletes been cater to us and they were
they need so oh yeah they need some
all the way she needs someone to hold
her hand and it was like a mother figure
it wasn't it was like let me get
everything in order for you let's set up
your household like we'll get all sorts
of people to help you Vanessa Williams
she never won Miss America but she lied
about right Oh bro shoot bro when I
don't know or the basketball player
practice he'd she was there at the
practice giving rookies her card yeah
sure is
clients yeah it imagine if she was legit
it should still be in business there I
know but she don't invest she didn't
even know she do that that's the saddest
part is when you think about it it's
like all this month time that my money
sat with this person just being spent
it wasn't being invested it's not they
didn't even try it in there yeah it
would have grown more in a savings
account it was all gone so you just
you're just sending statements and your
money is already gone uh Ricky Williams
he found out because he went to go draw
money how do you Rodman find out Rodman
found out I can't remember Oh No yeah
his ex-wife no no really it was found
out because IRS bill wasn't paid was
also filing their taxes yeah there was
uh there was a life insurance I didn't
get paid that they were old they all
knew the old $18,000 that was on Dennis
Rodman that's what it was it was like
18,000 and it was back owed and they
canceled his life insurance probably a
five million dollar life insurance
shouldn't pay the bill so it lapsed and
he couldn't get coverage in time for
something that he had yeah he wanted and
so uh
oh that was an annuity I think it was
like coming due yeah so yeah it was um
you know there in Korea asking Kim Jong
for my said but he's made his money back
I think people just like thinking like
the episode on American greed before
that one it was just on regular white
chick lying that she's like she's gonna
put our art gallery together yeah and
she meets this girl random girl who
writes for a magazine writes for a
magazine she told all her blah blah blah
and that girl who I somebody believes
that bra long story short they start
planning all this [ __ ] and they get to
that hotel business trip to Greece right
then she goes oh I can't find my wallet
no your card she said alright sixty-two
thousand dollars right yeah cuz there
was like a pool you give someone you
wouldn't give me your card I wanna give
you my card whatever you know I mean
it's crazy
yeah it's so I mean I'll give you my
card okay so because I know you yeah it
was a weekend and more so you haven't
even know for a year you gotta be out of
your [ __ ] mind it was like oh you
don't have no leads to this person like
okay you met me you met Reza you met me
there's the connection but there's no
connection to this people there's no
connection to these people that could
tie them to you once you're gone they're
gone forever yeah yeah and they do they
do when they show up somewhere else but
it takes so much work sitting next to a
person knowing I don't have any cash
that's true normal people normal people
but how do you lack the party you're a
man that's how you say like Psychopaths
oh and one of the guys wives one of the
athletes wives in the other case she she
was telling she was confiding in this
woman man you know we got an idiot to
know she was confiding because she was
like you know Africa whose wife it was
and she was she was saying you know we
got scammed by somebody in his fan in
his own family and so leave so what she
said we've taken such a hit financially
she's like well here's my card
like how do you hear I love you too I'll
Rob you a little bit more
dude no family oh he didn't get it all
let call me you know and it was like
some regret it Maggie but you don't have
a girl you're gonna have you get you
gotta know this do what you got to do of
course there you gotta be a calculated
thinking like ten steps ahead of
everybody or you're there when they
arrested a woman they arrested her in
her apartment in New Orleans oh yeah
apartment party word man with no money
she was just like what just laughs stuff
and everything and she had married six
very wealthy husbands like one was an
anesthesiologist one was oh it was weird
it's like she got something from that
relationship it was very interesting
hey the [ __ ] people desire huh crazy bro
for reals matter what man masca we get
robbed by family members E oh yeah
robbers for like you know they always
200 bucks for 17 years
hey you know they get locked up and use
your name like Angel didn't social
security get a job or something you too
I heard like that's having my family
yeah there were two I even brought
somebody stole I think what every
relative story is his social security
number and your family is to install
them bro but if somebody does use your
Social Security you're gonna get all the
credit at the end you mean to work yeah
because that's what they do they'll file
your taxes and they'll take your return
that's what happened to Felipe that way
they took his return cuz I know a lot of
people and I've heard of life since I
was a kid that they use somebody social
to get a job and then you know
I mean I've never heard anybody taking
the return some way I told my identity
to better themselves
what's up fool but they met people
people fall for anything huh
but do you want to make money when I got
the commercial you know it seems you
know living lavish the yeah but she
doing that to other people you say yeah
a whole bunch of clients from the after
that that's when they like I was trying
to call him and then they like went out
of business and then they fleed what the
money dude are they didn't did they end
up going to jail or what happened I
don't happen to him but they don't have
the business anymore they got sued a
bunch of times but no criminal charges
to the homie bloss TVC soda I went up
the [ __ ] oh that Club the [ __ ]
crab trap I love to trap we do a comedy
show Stevie see right there see that
name up there people know that name DJ
Mambo showed up or the horn right here
right there man Stevie see Marion that
guy well before there was a comedy club
in Oxnard before with a comedy club in
Ventura
Stevie see whether it was the man man
yeah we were booked comedy shows bro
that for you to book part I'm George
Lopez
really for us for $200 Danny April me
$200 brought the lobster trap Reuben
Quintana [ __ ] [ __ ] what's that Willie
Barcena and I were selling Polaroids
after a show bro
that's hilarious others each Dan 10
bucks back then that's totally cool dog
yeah that's cool hard it was to squeezy
a rubric in Donna
Marty Malloy I mean El Paso - yeah
that's cool man but love to trap row
where all the Karma's got crabs so what
time for Stevie see when he moved other
lobster trap he started doing her show
that the hotel we stay in the hotel
right in front of the beach now on
Sheraton the Sheraton you don't mean the
Victor dollar place no okay then the
residences at the Residence Inn he would
do shows there bro I took at the banquet
bro
uh-huh and dancing after bro do all
kinds of people show up bro let me tell
bro there was a hardcore people there
bro like like I'm punching me I would
eat a star like where the husband is
wearing a Pendleton in a [ __ ] fedora
so is the wife those people party out
there man they party bro one time we did
a show at George Perez at that time into
Harbor economy club and after that the
people Vytas so bar to go drink and I
was driving into George's with me is
like a Rizzo
don't get mad me I might do cocaine
tonight I'm going all scared George
Perez let's go party of my place bang
about n bro yeah Ventura and if you
doing meth out of the guys knife we went
to go to a house you took off with
somebody yeah yeah yeah that was me
Martine Willy and Ivan and the dude was
just [ __ ] cutting up coke rose on his
fender on his Harley so the best time
bro you go home with a string a stranger
and sorry we really ghost with a strange
couple broker they're trying to outdo
each the last party they had yeah that's
not funny color Navarro what's up fool
that's so funny man all right it's
[ __ ] nuts
what's up fool everybody here we're
gonna be shows coming up
well this Friday Washington to finish
this tapas that the name of the tribe
tops burger I don't know if this name of
this city name of the casino cause I'm I
mean name of the city yeah and don't you
have a corona virus to worry about
oh yes dead people in the tri-cities are
chewing at my two and a half miles away
- Marshall yeah
two and a half from China the ones that
came from Italy they died no one that
died were old people in a nursing home
and they think that somebody who visited
the nursing home it died that person
died or has it I can't remember in
Alabama or something like that or
somewhere over South Carolina I can't
remember where it was over on the East
Coast
south-southeast and they had visited
that nursing home brother
I don't think they know the source of it
at the nurse
there's a contaminated cache I sprayed
the coral virus that's what somebody
said on the comment strippers be careful
man
me dropping from those poles like that
lady do you think I made it rain wash
your hands after handling the money at
the show wash your hands after shaking
hands at the meeting yeah like all the
time not just after the bathroom after
all I can't hit that Lilly no more with
you with anybody doing that anyway I
don't want to be a dick or nothin but
[ __ ] you don't want to get sick cold
sore TV see Marco Sandoval John Anthony
Ramos jr. but Berto rod he says uncle
died from hearing it too many Corona
enough of the corona virus ha ha ha
ready ok people thank you very much for
listening don't forget to Like us on
instagram like us on snapchat like us
everywhere man
first person to do a graffiti somewhere
and say listen to the words of a podcast
get free tickets and meet and greet here
yeah but you got a post-it
what so Food City [ __ ]
you